مساء الخير ما هو تفسير موقف الجزيره
القطريه التابعه للحكومه القطريه الداعم
بشده للمقاومه الفلسطينيه والمعادي للكيان
على الرغم من العلاقات القويه بين الحكومه
القطريه والولايات المتحده الداعم الاول
والله انا القصه دي استاذنك في حلقه
بعنوان ماذا تريد قطر هي حلقه قديمه لو
كتبت كده ماذا تريد قطر او لو بحثت حتى
بكلمه قطر على قناه نعرف ان شاء الله ه
تطلع لك الحلقه من حوالي سنتين اظن ان
فيها تفسير مقبول لكن اجابه سريعه هي قطر
خدت من البدايه سياسه خلاصتها كالاتي انا
اهم دوله عندي في هذا العالم هو الولايات
المتحده
ولكن انا لازم يكون لي دور قوي حتى انا
انا دوله صغيره غنيه لازم احافظ على
استقلالي واستقلال قراري خصوصا من الدول
المجاوره الاقوى مني وعلى راسها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه علشان انا ابقى دوله
احافظ على استقلال ده تفسيري لازم يكون ل
دور
مهم الدول الكبيره ما تستغن عنه وعلى
راسهم الولايات المتحده هذا الدور هو انه
قطر تكون على علاقه بكل الجماعات
الاسلاميه اللي في العالم حماس الجهاد
طالبان الاخوان المسلمين كل الاسماء تبقى
هي الوسيط اللي من خلاله هذه الجماعات
بتتحدث مع كل القوى الكبرى الولايات
المتحده غيرها علشان هي الولايات المتحده
في حاجه لقطر كوسيط طبعا مع وهي قامت بدور
مهم جدا في الوساطه مع طالبان ودور مهم
جدا للوساطه مع حماس طيب ده يرض الولايات
المتحده ويرض كل دول العالم انا محتاج
دوله تكون هي قناه للتواصل وتاريخيا دول
كتيره لعبت هذا الدور مش مع الجماعات
الاسلاميه بس ولكن مع جماعات
مختلفه لكن علشان قطر تقوم بالدور ده لازم
تكون سياستها مقبوله من هذه هذه الجماعات
والا هذه الجماعات سوف تعتبرها جماعه
معاديه دوله معاديه ليها وعليه الولايات
المتحده مضطره ان تقبل هذا الخطاب
الاعلامي المؤيد للاخوان وطالبان وحماس
ولغيرهم علشان قطر تقدر تستانف دورها
كوسيط مهم جدا في صراعات حيويه لا تستطيع
الولايات المتحده ان تتواصل مع اطرافها
الا من خلال قطر هذا تقديري لو كانت
الاجابه مش واضحه استاذنك اكتب الي مره
اخرى وان شاء الله احاول اوضح